jonah is with us in pittsburgh hi jonah
what's up
hi dave it's jonah uh sorry i'm nervous
um so
i'm calling because my husband and i
have about over two hundred seventy
thousand dollars worth of debt
in student loans as much stuff and we
paid about a hundred thousand of them um
good lord for what i'm a nurse
practitioner and my husband
had a couple of things that he wanted to
do but i'm having trouble hearing you
your voice is all over the place can you
speak directly into your phone please
yes i said i'm a nurse practitioner and
my husband's a social worker
and you have 270 thousand dollars in
student loan debt
uh i mean a bunch of others like there
was about 30 40 000 worth of like credit
card and consumer debt too but nothing
it was all student loans
okay so my question was um
about 20 000 or so or is about a parent
plus one that my mom
is under my mom's name and i wanted to
know in terms of like baby step two is
that
like an honor like snowball or is it
something we should do later because i
mean
we plan on paying it but i didn't know
if we should just you know go through
the steps first and then
come back to it at some point or just
slowly pay it so you have taken
you have taken emotional and moral
ownership of this debt even though it's
legally not yours
correct yes my family's never been great
with debt
and money so yeah they're you're great
with debt that's for sure you got a
bunch of it
yeah i hate it i'm trying to get rid of
it we've been doing this since 2019 now
okay so cool you're you're just going to
put this in your debt snowball because
you're going to pay off the parent plus
loan
okay that's good to know you're treating
it like it's your debt right
yes i'm thinking like well the problem
is is that my sisters took out
parapletons too so they all kind of like
meshed together
so i'm not really sure like which one's
mine and what
you need you need to get a real sure
accounting so you know when you're done
yeah definitely even if it's not a
certain loan you just come to agreement
with your parents that
i'm paying twenty thousand four hundred
and twenty two dollars and after that
i'm done or whatever the number is
okay that's good i've always just
wondered this question
because this is this is a never-ending
thread you're going to pull on this
sweater otherwise
yes and i want to die forever hey
man yeah 270 000
[Music]
can't breathe it's just so normal now
it is and and and just the amount of
time and
income you have to dedicate to paying
backwards that's just such an
uphill climb yeah we uh climb we just
finished up the rams
research team just finished a survey a
study done and they found that
44 of the people with debt are losing
sleep at night
oh i believe that because of that i
believe i'm like
that means the other 65 are sleeping
they're they are
fifty-five percent they are feeling good
about their decisions i'm just trying to
understand
neither are good 78 are worried about it
what's the other 22
doing you know i don't understand
i always wonder about these statistics
that we come up with around here
of course they're losing sleep i
remember being that scared couldn't
breathe
wow